mais d'abord on revient sur un appel à
la grève inédit demain vendredi dans
toute la france certains parents
m'emmèneront pas leurs enfants à l'école
une prise de position claire pour
contester le port du masque obligatoire
pour les enfants de 6 ans et plus dans
les établissements scolaires s'il est
difficile d'estimer l'ampleur de ce
mouvement et ces voix discordantes se
font de plus en plus entendre
rencontre avec une maman de la riche qui
demain gardera sa fille à la maison
romain delville pour cette famille de la
riche le masque à l'école pour leurs
enfants de cp ce et non la visière à la
rigueur des demies groupe pour respecter
les distances ce serait mieux ses
parents d'élèves assimile le port du
masque à l'école primaire à de la
maltraitance c'est l'incompréhension
mélanger à la colère au mois de juin et
les enfants ont repris l'école en
petites quantités bon petit groupe
il n'avait pas le masque en septembre on
a repris l'école mais frontières mambé
tous les copains copines vous n'avez pas
le masque là on arrive sur la deuxième
vague
on reprend le 2 novembre pourquoi le
masque surtout qu'ils n'avaient pas
avant
vingt mille élèves de primaire sont
concernés par ce nouveau protocole
sanitaire en indre et loire
selon l'inspection académique trois
familles refusent le masque pour leurs
enfants à l'école le dialogue est engagé
même si du côté de l'éducation nationale
c'est le décret du 29 octobre qui fait
foi
celui qui instaure le port du masque
obligatoire en prenant aussi appuyé sur
les différents arguments que peuvent
représenter les médecins me sous verre
nous serons amenés dans ce dialogue à
construire une logique de réponse
positive autour de ce port de masques
mais je reviens au delà des enfants
handicapés
il peut y avoir des enfants et des
pathologies qui ne relèvent pas de
handicap et qui sur présentation d'un
certificat médical peuvent être
effectivement dispensés du port du mans
demain vendredi jennifer girard ne
présentera pas sa fille à l'école en
signe de protestation et autant de
vendredi qu'il le faut annonce-t-elle
tant que les élèves n'ont pas tomber le
masque